la dernière fois que j'ai rendu visite à
mon oncle il m'a gardé en otage pendant
6 mois
merci c'est ouvert c'est bon bonsoir
Thierry merci de m'avoir invité super
plaisir moi j'ai bien maté j'ai bien
maté l'émission de maloche tout ça et
ça m'a un petit peu remué parce que on a
beaucoup parlé de tu vois on a beaucoup
parlé des États-Unis on a beaucoup parlé
de du Moyen-Orient et du problème
israélo-palestinien tout ça et toi moi
ça me touche particulièrement parce que
parce que ma mère est juive et mon père
est arabe
et ils sont un petit peu en guerre en ce
moment
donc voilà donc voilà c'est donc je suis
juif et arabe à mon avis mes parents
m'ont eu uniquement bombers
je suis juif et arabe je sais pas si
vous imaginez le nombre d'ennemis que je
peux avoir sur terre le nom de personne
qui me détestent en même me connaître
c'est pas facile d'être juif et arabe
vraiment pas mais parce que 50% arabe
pour un juif c'est de toute façon déjà
trop et 1% juif pour un arabe c'est
juste un pensable que des problèmes
mes parents voulaient m'appeler Shlomo
ben Youssouf
allez deux familles étaient pas d'accord
finalement c'est l'ONU qui a décidé
ah c'est pas facile d'être juif et arabe
vraiment pas surtout en France parce que
moi à chaque fois que je passe une
soirée avec des copains et qui se
mettent à raconter des blagues [__] il
y a deux blagues sur trois qui me font
pas rire
et encore j'ai eu de la chance j'aurais
pu être blonde
un psychologiquement ça m'a complètement
[__] la tête vraiment c'est moi je me
suis déjà jeté des pierres
des relous c'est vraiment c'est pas
évident c'est vraiment pas évident en
plus avec les manifestations pro
palestiniennes le samedi les
manifestations pro israéliennes le
dimanche
j'ai plus un seul week-end pour moi
c'est vraiment c'est une situation
délicate quoi c'est-à-dire que c'est que
la moitié de ma famille est juive et
l'autre moitié de ma famille est arabe
la dernière fois que j'ai rendu visite à
mon oncle il m'a gardé en otage pendant
6 mois
non je sais plus quoi faire moi avec
toutes ces conneries je sais pas s'il
faut que je sorte avec des filles juives
ou s'il faut que je sorte avec des
filles arabes
du coup je sors qu'avec des Françaises
ma dernière copine sa famille était très
française
quand ils ont appris qui j'étais ça leur
a fait deux mauvaises nouvelles d'un
coup
je me souviens la première fois que j'ai
la première fois que j'ai été mangé chez
eux ils étaient super gêné
[Musique]
couscous
non c'était des racistes de base
vraiment à la fin du repas ils m'ont
fouillé
façon ça a pas vraiment tenu le coup
avec cette copine parce que elle voulait
pas se convertir deux fois
et pour moi c'était vraiment important
parce que je voulais pas choisir entre
les deux religions vraiment je me suis
lancé à fond dans les deux religions
j'ai passé trois ans à traduire la Torah
en arabe
j'ai très vite arrêté après avec tout le
trip religieux tout ça parce que
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
mais moi si je respecte tous les
interdits de mes deux religions
le seul truc que j'aurai le droit de
faire c'est boire de l'eau le mercredi
soir après le coucher du soleil
en plus c'est un shabbat pendant le
Ramadan c'est super cher
merci beaucoup bonne soirée merci merci
Thierry et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu